welcome to this video playing lunatic ex
yeah don't know I have played him
sternly this is this michalek guy Peter
wish Alec Michalek or something yeah I
played them before Chad don't remember i
forgot fifty percent result at least so
check explain a simpler fashion they are
taking on d 2 yeah i have a 50-percent
result that's not bad it's very high
rated to 630 is really high in the
five-minute pool okay my voice is
failing me a little bit early in the
morning so I wanted to play rook c8
Queenie for may be okay Quinn a for
Bishop c4 not c4 be five is my idea it's
a neat little tactic against Queen a4
maybe I can play it with FC eight and
then c5 that's the idea here to get get
in c5 you might play a father and I
should have thought about this a little
bit more if form
and charm that's not not really great if
he gets an e4 without any kind of
problem then I really made some mistakes
there in the opening it doesn't look
right but we are sitting passively
cannot be the solution so take that a
couple of times yeah it's got t5 okay
let's let's take yeah my bishop one is
six is just just not particularly well
placed there are those 95 ideas things
like that came and there's some planned
sd5 coming up so I really have to move
the Queen Queen c7 maybe I d 5 piece and
then maybe t5 or something like that d5
immediately is also possible maybe I can
take group the age that Madhya that
might be okay okay just takes okay I can
take with both
it's both possible the idea of taking
with the pawn is to possibly use the
default square some some point like a
bit should be seven maybe if I can let's
get this back it's a really a terribly
placed piece sometimes you can put
something on deform not sure that I
understand queen g5 maybe it wants to
trade queens I don't know why I take
that anyway now place them like that
okay I cannot play looking for maybe
kick it back here a bit okay look at you
6s giving up the D file that's not an
idea v5 you might play Bishop g5 so
let's just play and noncommittal miss
Knight to d4 that would be nice it's
their way to get there I don't know
maybe 96 is seven f5 this kind of thing
it's a bit a bit of a funny idea
don't I don't really understand his
concept him but I know that from earlier
games against him I never understood
anything and then I still lost my book
I'm just fine now with the chances to
get the bishop under the knight on d4 so
here's going what we should be home
probably 94 I queen three four okay
let's see what happens
check
right f5d force my dear check yeah I got
them that's nice what don't get that one
should check him let's see what he's
doing in I don't I don't have a clear
way forward though I mean I'm okay
definitely leave it I don't have them
ever greater plan forward maybe i can
put queen on d6 here and push the pawns
okay i can i can try
jenna maybe i should just do nothing I
mean time morning
yeah maybe I really should have done
nothing would be better would have been
better
I'm going for a 43 now check
yeah I should have just sit and wait I
mean yet absolutely nothing that can't
do in this position the only way for him
to do something yeah I what I did like a
check myself trying to use tegus office
basically sitting around play check
check check no blunder that one you had
it and check weird gaming yeah okay come
on black resign yeah maybe I should just
sit around I mean here is a position i
kind of just sit and never nothing ever
happens but black is just better so i
wanted to do something but this is
difficult basically was just just doing
nothing the whole game and waited until
I killed myself yeah I mean I should
probably just be content with the draw
because of the time situation yeah but
it feels bad it feels wrong right I mean
you basically outplayed the guy and then
you just make a draw like that even if
you're a minute down but um yeah here I
got I got two confused I'm in here like
still a jack white quite decent decent
plain chant it's not enough it's not not
enough red jack yeah I never understood
anything what you did there to be honest
I never understood anyone so this
structure is this is fine for black
anyway it was very weird he allowed me
to trade that and then here I'm just
fine I mean totally fine
two traded ropes which was which was
kind of strange so yeah here's exactly
what i want i have the the better minor
piece sanji even allowed me to go to d4
so that's kind of what you want check
but it's difficult to do something
without taking any risk I are here
Queenie for was strong yeah I wanted to
watch the before square but of course
you cannot play before here that's very
good that's a very good news now if he
goes before I have this move him it's
very very awkward he has no way to cover
the bishop check okay that that was much
stronger that was much stronger and
white will loose the pawn ok yeah Quinn
b6 was the simpleness yeah maybe I
should just shuffle maybe I should just
shuffle I mean but as mentioned it feeds
bad yeah if you're just better you
should try to win but I don't know I
don't know if this is the right plan
anyway to move the pawns mm-hm that's
difficult probably you have to do that
not sure about the precise position
though maybe maybe better from here I
can screen e5 jam ok I think he five was
almost may be ok but it's not easy his
invasion of the Queen white is
completely passive there with the bishop
and so on but still not so easy to break
down yeah what can you do thanks for
watching